hey what's up guys my name is achernar
welcome to episode 32 of game
programming so last episode we took a
look at this corner pin kind of thing
where we in inside inside of the level
class we actually added I guess the four
corner pins which basically define which
area of the map we want to render and
again it's very important as as we as we
talked about so today we're gonna
actually talk about how we retrieve the
tile that we need to render so in other
words this code right here specifies
which tiles we actually need to collect
and then what comes next is actually
like we're in a way to be able to to be
like alright I'm I'm up to rendering
this this pixel on the screen which tile
needs to be there so what is the
position of every tile how does that
work and the way that works actually is
we just make a new method called get
tile and that method will like literally
retrieve the tile that we need to render
so in other words
probably easy to show actually but um
basically you'll see that at the moment
we've like got this random um level
right here and what's gonna happen is it
gets is generate it generates and it
actually gives us a number between zero
and three all right
and number one out of four numbers it
gives us um ranging from zero to three
and then what we basically want to say
now is if that number is well let's just
say it's two if that number is two then
let's pop grass tile there that's sort
of how our random randomly generated
level is going to come come together so
to actually retrieve the tile at a
particular location we need to make a
get tile method so we'll obviously make
this in the level class just because it
is well it applies to all levels because
all levels have tiles and what we'll do
is we'll just go public tile
now this isn't void right the type is
tile because that's what we'll be
returning and I'll talk about I'll talk
a little about a little bit about that
in a minute
so public tile get tile and then in is
take two parameters and simply put it's
just x and y so in other words it's the
position of the tile that we're trying
to get now yeah all right so let's just
talk about that for a bit so now when
when we actually set a return method of
something not to void void means it
doesn't return anything right that means
that it just execute this code and
that's it that's it it's just execute
this code now public now if it's tile
for example right let's just import that
while we're at it
if
we said it's a tile this method actually
needs to return a tile object it just
needs to return a tile and it might be
difficult if you're like new to
programming might be difficult difficult
to actually understand this aspect of
like what does return mean was that mean
that means that when we run this method
it actually returns the data to us and
we can use that data to figure out
certain things or to execute that in
certain commands or in this case to
render certain tiles so based on which
tile this this method actually returns
which which tile object it returns that
is actually dependent like it depends on
what it returns that's what will render
will be rendering what this returns so
in other words well yeah I guess that's
probably the best explanation I can give
I it would it'll return a style and
that's the tile that will render so we
need to actually get a specific tile so
the tailor will be getting is actually
at this at this location right X&Y so in
other words
you know X is obviously well exercised
on the robots vertical but the thing is
we'll get to a particular point listen
between these corn pins because remember
we've divided days by four sorry we've
divided this by 16 we've shifted them
right by 4 and so what that means is
this this pixel precision is getting
converted into tall precision now and
then so in other words it'll actually
figure out which tile whereas we might
be a tile than three and then when it
gets that tile right it'll it'll we'll
plug in this value into here
basically we'll actually need to process
it a bit because as you as you can see
we're trying to go from X 0 to actually
X 1m and um-hmm process a bunch of
values here but well we're gonna like
plug in the x coordinate to here the y
coordinate the coordinate into here and
then hopefully you know inside this
method will actually figure out which
tile were actually rendering at that
point in time so without further ado
let's get on through actually how this
works so this is kind of generalized
because remember we do have around a
Louisville hospital just pop over here
so yeah I mean in the in this case right
tiles is being set to a particular
number so tiles are being set to a
number from zero to three so in other
words what we need to do here and it's
actually very simple all we need to do
is we need to say that okay so what are
we trying to do right this is
programming this is logical think about
what you're trying to do we're trying to
figure out which tile we won't render
and so far we've only made one tile the
grass tile and what we know about that
is that if tiles let us say if it equals
zero in other words if this randomly
generated number this remember this line
of code generates a number between 0 and
3 if that randomly generated number is 0
let's put a grass tile there right so
let's just literally type that if tiles
X plus y times width is equal to 0 then
let's just return a new grass tile but
will actually be returning tile doc
grass so a static version of that tile
and that is literally as simple as it is
right it scans through the river
um I talked about how X plus y times
width sort of gives you the coordinates
where the X is the literally x
coordinate and Y is just the
y-coordinate and that's it it's just
working like coordinates on a Cartesian
plane yeah well remember we're plugging
in the coordinates we want into these
parameters and then yes civil as that we
literally just look up on the map the
coordinate of the tile and
yeah you know we we look up the tiles
array and we see which tile is there and
if that tile happens to have the idea of
zero then this statement is true and we
return tailed or grasped now obviously
in this case it's not it's not always
gonna be grass right because this
randomly generates a number from zero to
three and it fills up a bunch of values
because we're going until we're
basically it's as big as as width times
height so that's gonna be a lot of
numbers and not all them are going to be
zero so we're this is why it's still
giving us this error because if this is
true is returning this one but if it's
not it's returning nothing but we need
to return something in this method so
we'll just type return null from now now
we'll change that because that's
horrible idea because we'll just get a
null pointer exception but um the point
is you know that's what's gonna happen
so that is how we rent a specific tiles
we also need to talk about making a void
tile now what a void tile is is it is an
actual it's like a null tile but it's an
actual object and the reason we do that
is so that if if we actually have to
render nothing we don't render nothing
we actually just render a black tile or
something with no down because if we try
rendering something that has no data to
it we're gonna get issues like screen
tearing and just bugs basically and
graphical glitches and stuff like that
because we can't render an area with no
data in it if that just doesn't work
that way
we need to fill it with some fake like
lack of toner so like in other words
just black pixels or we can make them
like white pixels or something if you
want but um yeah so we'll talk about
that next time but otherwise that is how
we actually retrieve it a particular
tile so um so yeah that's how that works
so I hope you enjoyed this episode of
game programming if you did again hit
that here that wonderful like button
because it lets me know that you guys
are still into this series and you love
it as much as I do and I will see you
guys see you guys next time goodbye
you